autre actualité en france la lanceuse
d'alert américaine frances aux gueules
rouges qui aujourd'hui à l'assemblée et
au sénat cet ancien cadre de facebook
avait révélé le fonctionnement interne
de la société en accusant facebook de
faire passer le profit avant la sécurité
de ses utilisateurs les précisions avec
notre reporter david perry fera devant
le palais bourbon
frances hogan s'est longuement entretenu
avec les députés une audition qui a duré
environ une heure quarante-cinq présidée
par ryan braun le pire est la présidente
de la commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale et roland lescure président de
la commission des affaires économiques
la lanceuse alerte a tenté de répondre à
un maximum de questions concernant
l'encadrement à des réseaux sociaux
députés comme à sénateurs étaient
curieux de connaître à les coulisses de
facebook etc à des rythmes notamment sur
le fait que les créateurs de facebook
perdre le contrôle à des algorithmes
l'objectif principal pour les députés
était de savoir si est ce qui est mis en
place en france et en europe est
suffisant pour protéger les individus
française hogen estime que le règlement
général sur la protection des données ou
les futures directives européennes
le digital services entre autres ont un
potentiel énorme qui pourrait à devenir
une référence à travers le monde une
fierté pour sacha houllier député de la
république en marche même s'il sait que
la france doit faire encore davantage
écouter la législation européenne et
française est bien différente de celle
que l'on connaît aux états unis c'est à
dire qu'on a des outils des outils qui
sont depuis les années 2000 et puis qui
sont nouveaux en 2022 avec le digital
services act qui va mettre à la
transparence sur les contenus qui vont
faire l'objet de censure ou de retrait
sur les motifs de retrait sur les
algorithmes qui sont seules à google
code de classement ce qui s'affiche sur
notre fil d'actualité facebook notamment
ou de recommandations ce qu'on nous
recommande pour adhérer dans des groupes
ou pour aller de venir quand même ça
c'est en france un dispostif on a déjà
avec un bon gros qu'on a déjà depuis la
loi séparatisme c'est un peu rassurante
ça veut dire qu'on n'est pas démuni e.on
a pris au sérieux le les difficultés et
ensuite on sait qu'on a encore beaucoup
de travail sur la question de
l'encadrement de toutes les plateformes
sur la question du statut des lanceurs d
alerte et de ce point de vue là il est
était assez intéressant pour nous
d'avoir l'intervention de madame hogan
juste avant l'examen de la proposition
de loi de nos collègues bazar man et nos
collègues du modem sur le statut des
lanceurs d'alerté en france françoise
sagan a tenu à remercier également le
gouvernement français pour ses prises de
position ou vis-à-vis des lanceurs
d'alerté coûter je suis ici parce que je
pense que les produits de facebook
nuisent aux enfants attisé division et
affaiblissent les démocraties et bien
plus encore
or l'entreprise c'est comment rendre
ses activités plus sûr mais elle ne le
ferons pas parce qu'elle met toujours
les profits colossaux avant la sécurité
des usagers la plate forme aujourd'hui
nuit à la santé à la sécurité de nos
communautés et nuit également à
l'intégrité de nos communautés afin de
soulever relever ces défis il faudra
faire face à des difficultés mais les
démocraties doit faire ce qu'elles ont
toujours fait lorsque les activités
commerciales ont un impact sur la
sécurité
des communautés et des populations il
faut que de nouvelles lois soient mises
en place et je suis reconnaissante au
gouvernement français de prendre ce
sujet accord à coeur je sais que vous
avez beaucoup oeuvré pour lutter contre
la désinformation et j'espère que la
pression continuera pour protéger les
lanceurs d'alerté la commission a par la
suite examiné à deux propositions de loi
sur la protection des lanceurs d'alerté
sur le rôle du défenseur des droits en
matière de signalements d'alert quand tu
affrontes cesse au ghana sera au sénat
cet après midi pour une autre audition